demain on se remet au travail bonjour
très cher baby corps oui pas son bébé au
rapport salue le père nu rose ils sont
toujours aussi sympa je ne peux pas
avoir un frère aussi ignorant que ça
dans l'art des affaires c'est gênant moi
je m'assure que le monde adore les bd
encore plus que les petits chiens et les
châteaux savoir quelle est cette grande
menace
quoi les chats sont des anarchistes à
venir de l'entreprise et un traitement
pour telle était plein fin j'ai rigolé
vente de plantes est joué
je commence à me sentir hyper mal à
l'aise besson fait quoi maintenant je
vais mettre le lion vous amuser bien
avec ton frère
rien du tout suspense tomboy je risque
de perdre son emploi
tu as fait un choix celui de rejoindre
cette famille on voit rouge fort précis
vous casser un peu comme forte de sa
poche oui médaille d'or pour spécial
vérité basse le chat il a pensé avant
nous 4 août
bouda tu ne peux pas tuer ce que tu ne
peux pas voir il est temps de passer en
mode invisible maman est la pire des
menteuses